are a child of the 80s or 90s you
probably got down with electric youth or
hanging tough and now you have the
chance to relive those times again
debbie gibson and joey mcintyre from new
kids on the block have teamed up to
bring you back i sat down with them both
to talk about their new residency and
how the two decided to take the show on
the road
i can't believe it i have two icons here
on the show today with me welcome debbie
gibson and joey mcintyre how are you
guys
sorry
hi mercedes
this is like a match made in heaven the
two of you here live in las vegas and
i have to ask how how did this come to
be on your own you guys huge superstars
but together now this is this is
fantastic whose idea was this
well you know i basically attribute all
the good ideas to joey um he
he initiated us doing lost in your eyes
on the mixtape tour
and then actually like you know about
almost two years later i was like you
know what the fans are demanding the
recording let's do it and joe was like
let's go one better and plan some live
shows in vegas
[Music]
in some ways i credit the pandemic
because um
you know it was it was a tough time for
all of us and and this song and
recording this song this number one
record that was already a huge record
that has become a special duet for
debbie and i you know to have something
during that down time was really
important as a performer and as a person
and
and again to piggyback on that you know
it's like just something to look forward
to i said let's let's put some shows
together you know so we can look forward
to something so our fans can look
forward to something do you guys expect
the residency at the venetian to
be as big as it is it's sold out you had
to add new data
obviously the fans have been waiting for
something like this what did you think
of the response
oh it was amazing i mean it was supposed
to be like two or three shows and then
it turned into eight you know i had gone
on ticket master because i had never
done that before i wanted to like see
what actually happens when people are
trying to buy tickets and it was like a
pac-man game they were getting gobbled
up
and i was like oh my god you know and
before you knew it live nation was on
the phone with us both going we had more
whose idea was the little greece tribute
that you do in the show my wife is a
massive grease fan so i remember when i
told her that and frankly that was sort
of like i i acted like i wasn't too
excited about it so then
i could act like i could give one to deb
you know what i mean when you have two
artists
you got it for a while you know debbie
was calling me dr no and that wasn't
really true
it was just that you know i'm gonna be
honest and not say you know yay to
everything i mean and of course she has
her her likes and dislikes too so
i i felt like you know that was a
no-brainer for someone something we we
both love to do obviously her history
and
it's fun to sing that song
you can see debbie gibson and joey
mcintyre live from las vegas there are a
few tickets left for the four remaining
shows september 16th 17th 18th and 19th
at the venetian resort las vegas to get
those tickets just go to venetian las
vegas dot com wow can i just say first
of all that was excellent and second
just a zoom full of heartthrobs right
there i know i was like reliving my
childhood dreams some electric youth
there i know i know that was a little
before your time rocky but i'm telling
you it was it was pretty cool it